au bord du canal de la loire qu'il
aimait tant à quelques mètres du chemin
de halage où il s'était fait
photographier pour sa dernière campagne
électorale
pierre bérégovoy s'est donc donné la
mort il était 18 heures 20 il venait de
passer un premier mais apparemment
normal fidèle à ses idées il avait
rencontré ici au palais ducal
les syndicalistes pour certains de très
vieux amis m'a paru tout à fait normal
quoique physiquement je ne les trouvez
touché parce que son aspect n'était pas
le même que d'habitude c'était pas le
piège détendu souriant il était
préoccupé il était triste pour moi c'est
beaucoup
cette année il pas excusez moi je suis
très ému quand je suis fatigué
l'après midi le maire de nevers est venu
saluer les vainqueurs d'une course
cycliste maury chômeurs y était là il
était 17 heures 15 gentil sourire mais
envoyait été affectés
il est monté en direction du podium et
chose que j'aime a surpris on a la forme
personne n'en a parlé quand le garde du
corps est descendu du passager de droite
avant droite avait un revolver dans le
dos juste au revolver que pierre
bérégovoy a subtilisé dans la boîte à
gants vous l'avez laissé
réglementairement son protecteur
prétextant une promenade il s'est
éloigné pour son chauffeur et son garde
du corps
il était trop tard pour empêcher le
geste fatal